San Francisco chaos has the power to
shock anyone who comes to town Dave
Chappelle giving a surprise performance
in the Golden State the Golden Gate City
excuse me and taking aim at his rampant
homeless crisis Chappelle asking the
audience quote what the bleep happened
to this place before comparing it to a
zombie movie and telling residents they
need Batman Chappelle's criticism comes
as the city is struggling to deal with
an estimated 38 000 people living on the
streets the city also has a major
problem with retail theft San Francisco
D.A announcing she will not charge the
Walgreens security guard accused of
fatally shooting a shoplifter saying
that the guard believed he was in Mortal
danger and acted in self-defense which
is pretty refreshing let's talk about
Dave Chappelle For a Moment Tyrus he
picks his moments I find like he doesn't
weigh in on every topic he doesn't he's
not always out there but when he wants
to make an impact he can like in this
situation well that's that's how you do
it you know if you have a talking point
on everything nobody listens and then
when you say something profound
they pay attention I I grew up in
California and there's this there's this
sediment where you can't speak ill of
your home state when it's going through
problems or whatever and uh I don't
believe in that I think it should come
from Californians to talk about the fact
that San Francisco is now basically a
shell of what it used to be literally
you can't have a business there you
can't you can't take your family out
there so what's going to happen with
this uh amnesty city is it's going to be
Zombie World there will be no businesses
I I think in the next two years there
will be no small businesses in San
Francisco eventually the major league
and as it continues to move up as it
continues to move into the gated
communities and the first worlders and
the wok and they can't get to their
season ticket games because the parking
lot's full of tents when that things
happen everyone starts moving when you
see major franchise sports franchises
leave the city of San Francisco maybe
then they'll pay attention but it's
going to be basically look like Mars I
mean there's just going to be no nothing
positive in the city the city is dying
and it's not just San Francisco
Heraldo he lives in your neck of the
woods now but he went out to San
Francisco to do this what is it about
perhaps Dave Chappelle saying something
like this in San Francisco that might
make a difference whereas if we talk
about it no one in San Francisco May
care Paris and I were speaking about it
before the program the thing about
Chappelle is he really does have a kind
of a Teflon that is extraordinary he and
Bill Maher they can say what is really
on their mind without fear of being
woked without fear of being uh you know
canceled and I think it is enormously
refreshing you know he made one
statement about the tenderloin which
always was the racy uh you know red
light district but it was more than that
it was it had color and he said the
whole city is now tenderloin in terms of
uh there's no more rules-based Society
anymore it's like anything goes and it's
really it's so it's so sad I I had
dinner last night with some some Pals
lawyers and journalists who were talking
about New York and you know because I am
a commuter now I I and maybe I only see
the the good I said well how is the city
doing uh you know and they to to a
person they said that it is now
deteriorated and that's a tragic tragic
to me since the pandemic and the George
Floyd riots and you know the other
things that have happened to us bail
reform
bail reform it's just that the good guys
seem to be losing we have to dig in you
need inspirational leadership I still am
hoping that Eric Adams is the guy
um let's go and talk about San Francisco
the D.A there Brooke Jenkins judge she
was brought in after the Soros back D.A
was literally recalled and she's got her
hands full but trying to do the right
thing I was very impressed you replaced
Chessa Boudin and she made a decision in
a case where a a Walgreen security guard
ended up shooting and killing a
shoplifter she made the decision uh that
she believed that the security guard
felt it was in moral danger mortal
danger I should say because the
shoplifter had a knife and apparently
was threatening to kill him and was
moving toward him with the knife so the
murder was dropped and she said look
there's no way that we could disprove uh
that he had to defend himself and which
is one of the you know the the theories
when you have a proper defense like that
it's affirmative defense but you know so
you've got you've got a good D.A in
place and that's the good news but the
truth is that San Francisco is the
second most hard-hit metropolitan area
in terms of threats in the nation okay
and the fact that it's gotten to that
level is a reason that it is in this
Decline and by the way nationally we've
lost 100 billion dollars to retail theft
by these organized criminal groups and
by the 30 percent of the homeless live
in California so it's like all set up
for this and then when you get some
municipalities that say look we're going
to send the cops out to clean up these
encampments and the judge ends up
Banning the police from enforcing
quality of life crimes against these
homeless people saying you know we're
not going to let you arrest those people
because they're homeless so now you
can't arrest people
um because they're criminals you can't
arrest them because they're homeless and
then if you have a business that's still
a business like a restaurant I think
Dave Chappelle who's saying he was
eating at a restaurant and someone was
defecating literally outside the window
so this is a recipe for the destruction
of one of the most beautiful cities in
the country and Jesse I was thinking
that with San Francisco the one thing it
might not ignore is celebrity criticism
they could take everything else but when
the celebrities come for them they might
react
San Francisco's like the Charlie Sheen
of cities remember Charlie Sheen a few
years back when he went wild and he
needed a makeover sometimes you just
need to take two years off fire your
manager go to rehab maybe get the
paparazzi to take a picture of you with
your children that's what San Francisco
needs they need to get out of the
headlines because every headline you see
flesh-eating virus yeah a toddler
overdoses on fentanyl popolosa gets
hammered in the head they need to chill
because this whole experiment with
social justice has blown up in their
face it has gone too far too fast and
it's starting to kill people and it's
killing the city of San Francisco
when you have a comedian like that that
talented ridicule you yeah ridicule is
powerful Jon Stewart knows that all the
late night people know it it's more
powerful than explaining why explain
when you can ridicule and especially if
it comes from the left San Francisco
doesn't listen to the five they listen
to Dave Chappelle and when Chappelle's
mocking them that actually might make
them wake up although I don't actually
think he had Indian food in the
tenderloin there's no good restaurants
there are you sure I'm positive I had
Johnny look into it do you want to fact
check Dave Chappelle yeah I know I know
that's a lot that's why he doesn't watch
keep it up water
I want to Brian kill Mead I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now